foreign
don't be scared
we've met before
are you looking for Reagan are you
looking for Reagan
Trainor
what do you think evil is
oh
tell you what I think it is
we're born in this world with Hope and
Dreams
and a desire to be happy
that's going on with my daughter
it's happening to my daughter too the
devil has one wish Wherever those girls
went they brought something back with
him
to make us lose faith I believe you can
help get our daughters back did you live
in this and the devil never gives up
she knows who I am
where's the other girl
[Music]
what you're doing here is dangerous
people have died on both sides of
possession
come on baby
if you don't make it I don't make it
what is it baby
I'm right here I don't want to go to
hell
God lead that Dragon
there are two heartbeats isn't working
they're beating in sync
what did you do
a girl lives one girl dies
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you